[Music]
we know a lot about Saturn we know it's
a gas giant surrounded by a system of
rings
we know it's orbited by a whopping 62
moons we even know that its North Pole
has a mysterious hexagonal cloud pattern
despite everything we know we still
don't have the answer to one very simple
question how long is a day on Saturn on
rocky planets such as Mars and Mercury
the length of a day can be easily
calculated through simple observation
but for gas giants like Saturn and
Jupiter figuring out day length is a
little more complicated than these
planets the interior layers of metallic
hydrogen are obscured by thick clouds of
gas that rotate at different speeds in
the planet itself what researchers can
do is track the magnetic field generated
by the spin of the planets interior for
most planets the axis of the magnetic
field is offset from the axis of the
planet itself Earth's magnetic field for
example is tilted 11 degrees from its
rotation axis Jupiter's is 9.2 degrees
this offset causes the magnetic field to
wobble
around the planet at regular intervals
each wobble causes a distinctive swing
in its radio emissions allowing
researchers to track the length of the
planets day for Jupiter Uranus and
Neptune this method worked perfectly
Saturn however wasn't so cooperative in
1980 and 81 the Voyager 1 in two
spacecrafts were the first to attempt to
measure the rotation of Saturn's
magnetic field based on those
measurements the length of a day for
Saturn is 10 hours 39 minutes in 24
seconds but when the Cassini space probe
made an attempt in 2004 it's reading
suggested ass attorney and day of 10
hours 45 minutes and 45 seconds nothing
in the solar system could cause the
planet to slow down so much so fast so
researchers concluded that the
measurements from both Voyager 1 and 2
and Cassini must be wrong the problem
seems to lie in Saturn's magnetic field
unlike the other planets in the solar
system the magnetic poles line up almost
perfectly with the planets rotational
axis making it incredibly difficult to
accurately measure the wobble of its
radio emissions researchers hope that
Cassini's final passes between Saturn
and its rings twelve years after the
first measurements would allow them to
better measure the magnetic fields tilt
and it's related radio waves
the initial passes were promising there
was evidence of a wobble in the data
that scientists believed could be linked
to Saturn's rotation rate however toward
the end of Cassini's final passes
researchers realized their radio wave
data were showing differences in the
magnetic fields rotation rate from
season to season and between the
northern and southern hemispheres this
meant that something other than Saturn's
core was affecting the rotation rate of
its magnetic field and accompanying
radio waves researchers believe these
low frequency radio waves are affected
by the density of electrons in Saturn's
magnetosphere and therefore are not a
reliable way to measure the length of
its day at the time of Cassini's last
dive the mystery was still not solved
however all is not lost the amount of
data collected during Cassini's final
passes was immense and it will be years
until all of it is properly analyzed an
answer could still lie somewhere in
those data until then researchers will
continue their work hoping that
eventually an answered to the question
how long is a day on Saturn is well
clear as day
you
[Music]